Oh.. p*tain comment ça marche ce truc?
Bon... Ça va aller comme ça...
Alors !
Non non, c'est bon vous pouvez continuer à manger !
Aujourd'hui on ne va parler que de choses propres !
Et en plus Romain est pas là.
Le mois d'avril arrive à grand pas et c'est cool !
Parce que ça va être l'occasion
de nous rencontrer.
Ça va même être les occasions de nous rencontrer.
Et oui parce que j'ai 2 nouvelles pour vous.
Si vous êtes Parisienne, Parisien
Francilienne, Francilien.
Ou si vous avez la possibilité de venir à Paris.
Sachez que je serai les 8 et 9 avril prochains
à Vidéo City Paris
Alors pour ceux qui connaissent pas Vidéo City Paris.
C'est un peu comme le Salon de l'Agriculture, sauf que
à la place des animaux et des produits du terroir.
Bah..y'a des YouTubeuses et des YouTubeurs.
Et y'a moi.
Vous pourrez venir au choix...
Nous siroter...
Nous déguster...
Ou flatter nos pelages soyeux.
Ou nos pelades soyeuses.
Selon les cas...
Non... En réalité c'est une immense convention
qui se déroule à Paris, Porte de Versaille.
Et qui regroupe un nombre impressionant de YouTubeuses et YouTubeurs.
Allez voir la liste sur le site, ça donne juste le vertige.
Avec au programme des dédicaces, des animations, des interventions sur scène, bref !
Venez me voir ça me ferait plaisir !
Vraiment !
Alors vous allez me dire...
"Oui ! Y'en a toujours que pour Paris !"
Alors déjà calmez-vous.
Et ensuite je vais vous répondre que j'étais y'a pas si longtemps au Japan Tours Festival.
C'est à Tours.
Donc pas à Paris.
Mais je vais aussi vous répondre que...
Je serai aussi au Zénith de Strasbourg
Les 22 et 23 Avril pour la troisième édition de la Néocast
qui est aussi une convention avec un nombre incroyable d'invités incroyables
Pareil je vous invite à aller voir sur leur site, y'a que du beau linge.
Et un programme aux petits oignons.
Là aussi il y aura :
Comme d'hab, je vous mets tous les liens dans la description.
Je vous chouchoute hein quand même...
Aller puis comme vraiment je vous chouchoute.
Je vous propose de vous faire gagner des places gratuites
ou des places a tarifs réduit pour ces 2 conventions.
Pour ça rendez-vous sur la page Facebook de Dans Ton Corps.
Le lien est où ?
Dans... dans la description.
Voila donc ça fait 2 belles occasion de se rencontrer dans le mois qui vient.
Il y en aura surement d'autres après dans d'autres villes.
Je vous tiens au courant.
Voilà donc ben... venez !
Je vous attends.
Venez.
Je suis là !
Ah m*rde putain Romain est pas là !
Ah oui et portez vous bien !